l'Ukraine qui a nouveau été visé ce
matin quelques heures avant c'est
commémorations on a réussi à envoyer de
nouvelles fluide missiles sur son voisin
l'essentiel des frappes viser Kiev qui a
voulu retrouver tout de suite notre
correspondant Emmanuel Chaze bonjour
Emmanuel les autorités
ukrainiennes qui affirment avoir abattu
23 des 25 missiles c'est cela
oui bonjour Elisabeth ce n'est que la
dernière série de plusieurs nuits
d'angoisse à travers toute l'Ukraine
mais principalement ici à Kiev quand on
parle de de centre visé par ces frappes
de missiles évidemment l'est du pays est
perpétuellement sous le feu de la Saurus
mais le reste du pays aussi plusieurs
nuits d'angoisse je le disais dont cette
dernière la nuit dernière donc la nuit
du 8 au 9 mai 25- à travers le pays dont
15 étaient destinés à la capitale qui
est alors au dessus de Kiev tous les
missiles ont été abattus par la défense
aérienne
ukrainienne mais lorsque ces métiers
sont abattus et bien ils font tout de
même des dégâts il y a eu un début
d'incendie dans un dans un jardin dans
la dans la région de Kiev et cette
fois-ci on déplore pas de blesser ici à
Kiev mais ces dernières 24 heures il y a
plus de il y a 17 personnes qui ont été
blessées par ces par ses fra c'est
frappes qui ont touché 139 objets à
travers tout le pays voilà des sirènes
qui ont donc retentit juste avant faut
le rappeler quand même l'arrivée
d'Ursula vanderlione qui est aujourd'hui
l'invité à Kiev en cette Journée de
l'Europe je crois que c'est d'ailleurs
exprimé depuis le sujet
oui tout à fait alors c'est une visite
qui était attendue même si c'est la
cinquième déjà de cela Finder Layenne ça
montre ça montre vraiment une relation
forte entre les institutions européennes
et l'Ukraine à un moment où aujourd'hui
et bien l'Ukraine a décrété que le 9 mai
serait désormais la Journée de l'Europe
au même titre que les États membres de
l'Union européenne c'est une décision
qui a été qui a été qui était salué par
Ursula fendelaian elle est arrivée ce
matin vous l'avez mentionné à cet
entretenu avec volody mir Zelenski et
Elisabeth je me trouve ici sur le sur la
place Sainte-Sophia sur laquelle se
trouve en ce moment une exposition qui
montre tous les liens tous les liens de
soutien dans le domaine humanitaire mais
aussi dans le domaine culturel apporter
par l'Europe à l'Ukraine en ces moments
difficiles et au fond vous le voyez
peut-être il y a ce drapeau européen à
côté du drapeau
ukrainien ça montre tout l'attachement